scott cook put it this way instead of
focusing on the competition
focus on the customer world-class
service gives us a competitive edge we
don't need to be obsessed with the
competition we need to be obsessed with
a customer
i love this quote from jeff bezos he
says we see our customers as invited
guests to a party and we are the host
it's our job every day to make every
important aspect of the customer
experience a little bit better and in
today's episode of the think media
podcast we're going deeper into how to
serve others
well my name is heather torres and you
are listening to the think media podcast
the number one podcast to help you grow
your influence on youtube
and then turn that influence into a high
impact and a high profit online business
and today we're going deeper into the
impact side you know over this year here
at think media we've been diving into a
book by our friend carrie newhoff at
your best and over the last uh year we
have done different sessions here on the
show we are in part three of those
sessions you can go back to episode 128
and 135 if you want to go deeper in
learning how to be at your best
personally with the right mindset and
energy for longevity as a content
creator and how the pursuit of mastery
will set you apart in your industry and
help you skyrocket to success today
we're going deeper though into that
impact side of customer service now you
might be thinking well heather i don't
really have customers yet i just have
subscribers or viewers on my youtube
channel well let me tell you you are at
the beginning of your customers journey
it starts with being a subscriber it
starts with being a viewer it starts by
being a follower on instagram and
whether you have something to sell or
not
it's important to understand these
principles of how to serve others well
so we're going to jump into today's
featured episode with sean cannell
talking all about how to be at your best
[Music]
today's topic session number three is a
commitment to service a commitment to
service
and here's the big idea
one of the reasons we want to be at our
best
is so we can help our customers be at
their best
i think a mistake that could be made
when it comes to
being at our best is to think it's about
us
well how do i just how do i just get my
my stuff right how do i just build this
i just want to be at
me
this is at me best i'm at me best is
that spanish for at our best um and and
you know it's all about me and and you
do need to have self care like you got
to put your oxygen mask on first in the
plane before you try to help your child
because if you pass out
because there's an oxygen leak in the
plane you're not going to be able to
even help your child who can't reach and
put up the mask themselves however
life is about serving others and so our
commitment to be well and our commitment
to excellence is because we live a life
of service so we're committed to being
at our best so ultimately we can help
our customers our community
be at their best
so today's topic is commit
to
service commit to service here's the
definition of customer service
it's the act
of supporting and advocating
for customers in their discovery use
optimization and troubleshooting of a
product or a service
and we do have a team called
the cr team customer relations team
cs customer service team it's not what
they're called but it's also what it is
but
i would challenge you even though we
have cr our entire company
needs to be a
committed to service
customer service is not the job of just
chris
or caleb customer service
is a company-wide philosophy
that we are committed to supporting and
advocating for our customers
to their discovery helping them find our
program like vra helping them use it
like are they actually using it do they
understand it
optimizing it making the user experience
better
helping them troubleshoot the product or
the service
it's not just what happens leading up to
the purchase it's actually the ongoing
experience the customer has
after the purchase
and a new voice media report though
reveals watch that poor customer service
is costing businesses
more than 75 billion dollars a year
wow
you know we have
we have a profit share at our company
and that goes out june 1st couple weeks
later about you know eight days later as
we calculate things and then it goes out
on november first our fiscal year at our
company is
december 1st to december 1st to get all
the dollars in before the end of the
year to be more strategic and smart
about taxes so we're coming up on profit
share
poor customer service though
is killing our profits
like poor customer service is costing
businesses around the world more than 75
billion a year and that was only 2018
and the number continues to rise the
report claims that brands are failing to
create a positive emotional experience
that drives customer loyalty and here's
what it discovered
one customers don't feel appreciated
you know maya angelou said it this way
i've learned that people will forget
what you said they will forget what you
did but they will never forget how you
made them feel
so people are working with businesses
right they're they're having customer
services experiences and they don't feel
appreciated
my one of my favorite
examples of this is every once in a
while when sonya and i will go on a
vacation to some kind of a beach town
like a laguna beach or uh to
snohomish washington up in the northwest
sonia loves little shops right she loves
like shabby chic you know
farm town shops art shop like clothing
shops candles i need to smell the
candles i need to find the she's a gift
giver she's shopping for gifts
you know when you go in these shops like
they're in business to make sales
and when you get the person though at
the at the front counter
at that's looking at their phone and not
only are they not acknowledging you
right
but they actually seem like they're
annoyed you're there right they actually
seem like it's a burden you walked in
they actually seem mad or disinterested
and i'll tell you this i definitely
don't feel appreciated
but on the flip side i've found that
when i experience a positive customer
experience you can get me in a buying
mood like you give me a good customer
experience
especially as a business owner i'm like
man i just want to give you money
because i feel appreciated it should
just be a 101 basic standard but how
remarkable would it be if everybody that
came and touched had a touch point with
think media felt appreciated now another
thing this study discovered was that
customers were not able to speak to a
person who could provide them the
answers they were looking for
so they wanted to talk to somebody
and this is one of the reasons why we do
click with think and talk with think
people want to talk to somebody they
want to connect with somebody this is
one of the reasons why we do chat but
it's also one of the reasons why we want
to double down on these
next is they had rude and unhelpful
employees
next customers were being passed around
to multiple people um
are we fully abreast into the details of
our catalog of our products so that
we're like i'm not sure let me let me
throw you over to another department
that reminds me of sometimes when i
might call into uh cox the internet
provider which i'm thankful for the
influence of talking to you in this
group and our podcast
not that i want to say anything negative
about them except for their customer
experience sucks
and where you would call in right and
hey could i get help with my internet
and and the person's like oh yeah you
know
one second let me put you on hold
and then it goes click and it leads to a
dead end so not only do you get passed
around i need to pass you around to
somebody else
that person picks up the navigation of
from person to person
has been 20 minutes here 20 minutes
there duh
a little bit of music in between only to
be
like what happened the line just just
stopped
and then the daunting dread
fills your very nerve nervous system and
the fiber of your being
i got to start the process all over
again
my gosh i'm being passed around to
multiple people
thank god for sonia my wife and
our cfo
who
is the queen of
being on the phone for state taxes and
payroll taxes
and and and new york and this or that
and people that don't even know like hey
could you tell us like what do we need
to set up to be set up in the state you
know to get approved for things and and
calling in to literally the people who
that's their job and they're like i'm
not sure let me pass you around to
somebody else you know what i mean
so customer service man it's 75 billion
dollars plus a year is being lost it
makes sense
and then customers are put on hold for
unreasonable lengths of time
here's a question what is our response
time at think media
here's a question how much are we
talking about our response time at think
media and here's a question what is our
goal to reduce our response time at
think media
and so it's kind of cool you look at
something like facebook it actually
rates the page typically responds within
15 minutes typically responds within the
day typically responds within an hour
metrics that matter 86 percent of
customers surveyed said that they
if there was an emotional connection
with a customer service agent they would
be willing to continue to do business
however only 30 felt that companies that
they interacted with in the past year
had made that connection
and so i want to thank you because i
really do believe we are at a remarkable
level at think media but we have a lot
further to go grow it's like we're doing
the best with what we have but we're
also committed to mastery which is a
beginning student mindset as good as we
are and people report and great uh
conversations that they have with our
team how love they feel and the culture
here beginner student mindset is man
we're just getting started and customer
service is not just our cr team if you
ever answer an email as content creators
we never want to just be
powerful and confident on camera with
the best content possible we actually
want to be the most loving and
empathetic in reacting to and responding
to the comments after we post a video
instagram comments matter dms matter
comments on nolan's videos omar's videos
matter and when they see a response as
much as possible to make an emotional
connection where this is not a tactic
this is births in real love and
authentic care
for our customers and our community so
who are our think media customers who
are our think media customers i think
that
for sure
they are people that have made a
purchase
they've purchased a book they've
purchased a course they've purchased a
ticket to the event they've purchased
coaching
who are think media customers
here's one that you may not think
there are subscribers in our content
viewers
you know brands are not going to pay us
nor is youtube going to pay us through
adsense if people don't watch our videos
so our content viewers and our
subscribers are our customers how are we
loving them and taking care of them
now who else are our think media
customers
brands we're working with
they're actually customers of ours
they're paying us
and so every brand interaction and we
have an over a million dollar a year
business in working with brands
so loving those individuals the
representative at the brand taking care
of
the
uh taking care of the relationship
responding quickly having that open
channel thinking that
the golden rule we want to treat our
customers our subscribers our content
viewers the brands we're working with
the way we want to be treated
communicated with quickly how about our
joint venture partners
you know our jv partners are just
anybody that we're able to promote as an
affiliate but man we got to stay
grateful and humble the fact that we
could actually collab with somebody yes
promote their their product or their
program or their event or their service
or their software but at the same time
they pay us
like if money's coming to us we got to
stay grateful
if money is transferred into our account
when we do a jv launch for someone else
man
as much as sometimes it could be easy to
get frustrated oh they didn't get us the
information oh things weren't going you
know
the back end didn't work is quite quite
as good as i thought it would no what's
the positive perspective they're our
customers we're the ones that get to
serve them even if it's their launch
that's our attitude at think media our
joint venture
partners yeah shayla says our vra
members are our customers right
we want to take care of them um
so anybody that gives us money directly
or indirectly are our think media
customers and listen
we always
think media creed time we always take
the responsibility in the relationship
that's what real leaders do
extreme ownership
yeah but it was on them like they was on
them to get me the stuff no we always
take responsibility in the relationship
that's what real leaders do and we're
real leaders
can there be a justifiable reason on
their end sure but we can never control
their end
we could be more diligent to follow up
in text in email to shoot an audio
message we can have the foresight to to
say hey the night before something hey
just heads up oh thank you so much for
my we can be the ones to go the extra
mile we always take responsibility in
the relationship
we want to serve our
customers
now who is responsible for customer
service at think media
is it isaiah
is it jordan and shayla when they're in
email inboxes or dms and and customers
are saying something is it brian when
he's in
uh dms and and community members or or
customers at any level
starter kit
book
you buy a book we got to honor that
relationship you share a picture of
youtube secrets on social media
like you're a customer man they've
invested money with us now tony shea
may he rest in power former ceo of
zappos
known for one of the greatest customer
service companies of all time
they were known for
when you start working there no matter
what your job is they made you spend two
weeks
taking calls with customers and in their
call center
no matter what your job was i think it
was at least two weeks if you were going
to be a high level executive two weeks
on the phone if you were gonna do social
media two weeks of the phone if you're
gonna edit video two weeks on the phone
and he said this customer service
shouldn't just be a department
it should be the entire entire company
i hope you are getting value out of
today's episode and you've not yet
subscribed to this show i'm gonna
encourage you to hit that subscribe
button on youtube or wherever you're
consuming this content on and we have a
brand new class for you if you want to
learn how to get to your first 1000
subscribers and beyond on youtube and
earn your first 1 000 without a fancy
camera years of editing experience or
even having to have a film degree you
want to go to
thinkmasterclass.com where i'll be
teaching you in a 45-minute class how to
actually get your first 1000 subscribers
and beyond so go to thinkmasterclass.com
i'll link that down below in the show
notes as well as the description on
youtube well let's jump back into
today's featured content
customer service isn't just up to our cr
team it's a company-wide commitment and
this is why
we do love bombs and what love bombs are
is at least once a week for 10 minutes
we try to respond to as many comments as
possible as many comments on youtube on
our multiple youtube channels as many
comments on our instagram posts and our
multiple instagram accounts as many
comments as possible on our tick tock uh
posts all all across the board and it's
it's pretty overwhelming but it's why we
commit to doing it and we're gonna do it
even more
and this is why it's so important that
we say thank you
and respond to as many comments as
possible with gratitude and appreciation
and this is why we pour our hearts into
the vra community our video raked
academy community
we deeply care deeply love them and we
want to remember customer service isn't
just awesome you bought the course piece
good luck
it actually becomes even more important
now that they're inside of the program
are they being communicated with on how
to use optimize and troubleshoot the
product they've already invested
in
this is why we did tech week a while
back
and we wanted to say especially during
the holidays that we wanted to be
showing up answering questions being
there live this is why we do the video
creation made simple workshop and where
daisy and chris and nolan and omar are
going the extra mile i mean in a way
it's not even the extra mile it's
actually just showing up and being
excellent for what people have invested
in to get their questions answered and i
want to thank that team for staying on
long and answering people's questions
and jumping on zoom and being there to
serve and caring about helping people
get their lighting right and their
camera right and their battle station
right
this is why
we make sure that on the front lines of
cr
that uh we genuinely care and love
people and the entire team does
you know this is also why we deliver the
best free information in the industry
and so i want to encourage you kyle
anderson and steph
de sevo
uh that
when you're editing videos and doing
them excellently and when omar is
breaking down
free game
and when nolan's sharing information
when heather's teaching people how to
make money
it's customer service and it's generous
it's free
we're given the best free information in
the industry
and then it's why
we're so committed to giving the best
free information in the industry
to viewers that we do earn money from
from ads and to keep that in perspective
that again cream rises to the top no
matter how many cups of coffee you pour
we
are not so saintly that we just make
free and uh you know free content and we
didn't figure out a way to monetize it
we get that ad revenue or we get those
affiliate clicks
but it's from a heart of service
and then we go even to a deeper level
when we pour our heart into our courses
content and community
so we've talked about
this need of customer service
it's losing 75 billion dollars a year to
businesses so even just improving this
area doesn't mean we even need to create
more revenue it means we'll actually
keep more revenue it means ultimately
that as word of mouth spreads we will
create more revenue and
we've defined who our customers are
we've defined who is responsible
for customer service at think media hint
all of us
and so i just want to land the plane
talking about three powerful results
of committing to service
three powerful results of committing
to service if you're taking notes write
this down number one
world-class service gives us a
competitive edge
world-class
service
gives us a competitive edge at think
media
scott cook put it this way instead of
focusing on the competition
focus
on the customer
it could be really easy
to actually
worry about our competition compare
ourselves to the competition
it can be really easy to look
at the grass on the other side
think that it's greener but that's just
because the light reflected wrong
secretly there's toxic poison underneath
the grass and and we just got to water
our own grass but ultimately
world-class service gives us a
competitive edge we don't need to be
obsessed with the competition we need to
be obsessed with the customer
we if we just serve and love and take
care for care of and steward those that
are here
watch
we will actually have
the greatest competitive edge against
the competition
so i love this quote from scott cook
that we don't need to focus on the
competition by the way i'm preaching to
myself today
at our all team leadership meeting
because i can get distracted by the
competition
and try to react to what they're doing
or copy what they're doing or do what
they're doing i don't want to be
obsessed with the competition i want to
be obsessed with the customer
and the competitive side of my nature
though
is it's a better obsession period
because it's a win-win you focus on the
competition you might miss out on
serving the customer
but if you focus on crushing it for the
customer the creator who understands the
viewer best wins you focus on loving
serving wowing over delivering for the
customer
my friends we will always
have the competitive edge
because truly loving and serving the
customer will make your competition
irrelevant
and i actually see this so much in our
community we need to help our students
understand this stuff that's why we want
to post this as a podcast we want all of
our students even if they don't have
quote unquote a product they do they're
creating content that they want
monetized online they got to be in the
customer service mindset
when you're truly loving and serving the
customer and you're obsessed with that
viewer man what are they thinking about
at night what are they worried about
what's on their mind how can i ail their
pains how can i help them overcome that
anxiety and that fear how can i help
them solve that really frustrating tech
problem how can i help them get results
on youtube how can i help them multiply
their income and create extra income
streams how can i help and serve them
the competition's irrelevant
if we're crushing it for our customers
and as our culture becomes more selfish
than ever
service stands out
so
world-class customer service number one
gives us a competitive edge one of the
reasons why is customer loyalty 91 of
customers say that a positive customer
service experience
makes them more likely to make a further
purchase
also investing in new customers is five
times more expensive than retaining
existing ones
and so
if we can create
world-class service
customer loyalty
will
encourage
our customers will want to buy other
stuff from us they'll want to do other
things with us
and
trying to constantly find new customers
is five times more expensive than
retaining existing ones
and and by making more offers to our
existing customers
because of world-class customer loyalty
so number one world-class service
gives us a competitive edge number two
world-class service results in earning
more money
the law of income states
you get paid in direct proportion to the
amount of value you deliver to the
marketplace
we have a service attitude
so
the amount of value we give
the other day on inner circle
i was doing some hot seat coaching and
the uh the individual goes my gosh i go
did you get value today and he goes man
i got so much value this
ten times
over delivered for what i've paid for
this program so far and i had already
gotten value from just watching the
recordings but this moment
and so
our income continues to increase at
think media well i hope it would because
it's a universal law that you get paid
in direct proportion to the amount of
value you deliver to the marketplace
money is the consequence of serving and
providing value to other human beings
it's not the goal see money is the
result it's the consequence of serving
and providing value to other human
beings
now this might sound kind of weird
because of course we're in business to
make money but there's two different
kind of spirits or attitudes business
owners media companies youtubers
youtube entrepreneurs content
entrepreneurs can come from one is they
can just be in the relentless pursuit of
money
two
subtle
subtle difference with
literally
massive consequences in terms of how
profound it is they could just be in a
rapid pursuit or a passionate pursuit of
serving and providing value
one entrepreneur one team is in the
pursuit of making money at whatever cost
one team is in the pursuit
of serving and providing value funny
thing is maybe person number one gets
money well maybe they don't and maybe it
doesn't last maybe they don't build a
real legacy and maybe they kind of lose
their soul in the pursuit of that
but what's fascinating is that if we
just become obsessed with serving and
providing value money is the consequence
it becomes a
byproduct
of truly serving and providing value and
to serve people you got to get to know
them first you got to understand their
wants
and their needs and that's why we again
are obsessed with helping people win
we're obsessed
with doing
keyword research and topic research but
also listening to comments so we can
truly serve people's wants and needs
now businesses can grow watch this step
from baining company businesses can grow
revenues between four to eight percent
above their market when they prioritize
better customer service experiences
so we can get almost 10 revenue growth
which directly flows into your pocket in
the ability
to
when it's appropriate and when revenues
allow into raises but also into the
profit share
aspect of our company
so just imagine us raising revenue by 10
there's so many different areas we can
raise revenue in but one that can
directly research has shown better
customer experience
four percent eight percent
uh better revenues
and
i discovered a new marketing method and
i know you're like sean you said you're
not going to do anything new
and we're not gonna uh you know do any
new initiatives but unfortunately today
i'm announcing one and it's a new
marketing method called wom
you know if you're watching this we're
listening to this
you need to write that down or drop that
in the chat or the live chat or the
comments or the itunes review
womb
w-o-m
crazy i mean with all the opportunity
there is on tick tock with all the
opportunity there is you know on youtube
with all the opportunity there is doing
a challenge
make an nft
you know
blow up your brand on the blockchain
this new marketing method is crazy
wom you know what it stands for
word
of
mouth
the newest marketing method that we want
to double down on think media because
we're committed to being at our best is
actually the oldest marketing method
that will always supersede all marketing
methods and it's simply this
word
of
mouth
94 of customers will recommend a company
whose service they rate as very good
94
so our question is what is our word of
mouth rating like how many people and we
are experiencing this how do we raise it
up
when they have a great
experience they'll tell other people
friends we
do all kinds of organic content
marketing and the content team works
really hard
to edit videos and edit shorts and edit
reels
and edit video podcasts and we do all
kinds of paid traffic and and we embrace
ads and we will continue to do those
things but the truth is
is that there could be a day when paid
advertising becomes unsustainable or
or or just hard to make profitable there
could be a day where organic reach
becomes frustratingly difficult
but one of the opportunities to
have our business marketed and continue
to grow is world-class customer service
it's not free because it's gonna take
our love and our sweat and our emotions
and sometimes listening to someone super
frustrated but talking them off the
fence or being there of being going high
when they go low of diffusing and we've
seen this happen in our company's
history of negative comments that have
come our way and you know different
things that have come our way and so uh
but when we
deliver
very good service we get that wam power
wom wom wom word of mouth man we want to
see word of mouth
and and one of the coolest things about
social media is it actually does a lot
word of mouth when people click that
share button on that reel when people
click that share button on that tick
tock when people repost or spread the
word or forward an email to somebody
because it was so valuable
then we are getting that wam power but
number three
is world-class service
is the path to real greatness
it's the path to real greatness
it gives us a competitive edge
it results in earning more money
but it's also the path to real greatness
jesus said it this way the greatest
among you will be your servant
wow
what i love about this is there was this
one story where a couple of the 12
disciples with jesus came to him
and they were like
hey bro
is it cool if omar sits on your right
and nolan sits on your left you know
and he was like uh
okay well this conversation is happening
and so he's like well listen it's not
for you to to get to decide who gets to
sit beside the throne
in in uh in heaven and in eternity
but he said listen man
uh
if you desire to be great
then you're gonna serve
then the path to greatness is service
but the coolest thing that happened was
the response wasn't
a rebuke to the disciples in the pursuit
of greatness and as a person of faith
i've found that
one of the biggest mistakes that can
happen for christians and in churches is
they misinterpreted scripture
somehow thought that ambition
for greatness is something that god
doesn't approve of
which is
anti what scripture and what the life of
jesus would teach
the pursuit
of greatness
of impact of significance
even of
wealth
the pursuit
of growth
and influence
is something that actually god blesses
however
he's so clear that says but listen
the true pursuit of greatness though
is service
you got to become like a child you want
to be willing to wash someone else's
feet
which is something we don't really do in
today's culture and i'm grateful for
but it was something that even the
god-man himself jesus christ bowed and
got on his knees to wash the feet that
were smelly
and that were dirty
of of peter who had walked
miles in the hot sun
my son my son is only 18 months old and
he plays with his little crocs out in
the backyard in the dusty vegas backyard
and i'm stunned by how stinky my son's
feet already are i didn't know i'm
already noticing my son's waking up with
bad breath my son's waking up with
stinky feet i'm i'm trying to clean
between his toes i'm talking toe jam
it is there is some toe
jam on sean bradley's feet and i'll
clean his feet off here's the thing the
god man
the creator of heaven and earth was
willing to wash feet the greatest of all
and so ultimately the world-class
service is is the path to real greatness
we are not afraid of pursuing greatness
of being in a city on a hill of shining
bright
we just want to be marked by
humility and and imagine a company
modeled after values like this
imagine a company modeled after after
values like sacrifice like putting other
people first like going the extra mile
like humility like unashamed pursuit of
impact and influence
and income
because we want to make a big difference
and the posture
of not just the leaders of not just the
c-suite of not just team directors but
of all team
from that is here today or that is here
tomorrow is that we just take that
posture of a servant
ain't nobody in culture want that
posture anymore
everybody wants to be their own king
they wants to be they want to be their
own they want to be the one they want to
flex
on social
they want to brag they want to boast
imagine a company though
that i actually think would with the
greatest flex of all
is that posture of service
and putting others first
and i think that the biggest trap we
could fall into
is thinking that this is about us
and one of the reasons we want to be at
our best and we commit to excellence is
because excellence will impact
our customers and our viewers and we
commit to wellness is because we can be
our best for our customers for our
students and for our viewers but also
for our families
we're going to be best at serving our
spouses our friends our families our
communities our local churches
our customers we're gonna be if we're at
our best but what's it for it's so we
can serve others and lay our lives down
so
the biggest trap we could fall into is
thinking it's about us when real service
or real greatness is marked by service
and
finally as the plane is officially
landing
i want to ask the question that who are
who are the heroes at think media in
terms of framing up
our
vision and our values
and
this was
a a friend of mine helped me understand
this his name's donald miller and he
wrote a book called story brand who are
the heroes that think media the heroes
that think media
and i believe all of you are heroes
listening to this but the heroes that
think media it's not us
it's our customers
and it's our community
and it's the people that we are
empowering to take action and to change
the world
and when donald miller wrote this book
story brand highly recommend it
he said that a lot of this is
counterintuitive in the influencer
culture because what all these youtube
creators think is they just think that
oh it's about me
and especially what with the highest
levels of influence or culture truly
is is just sometimes the highest levels
of selfishness
but imagine if it was actually like wait
a minute we're not the hero
the person we're serving is
and and donald miller makes the point to
say in our business
listen you're not luke skywalker
our goal is to be yoda
short
wrinkly
weird voice
right
our goal is to be yoda our goal is to be
obi-wan luke
was the hero of the story and luke
destroyed the death star so when we
think about our posture
of
think media even what we do what do we
do we're an education company so we're
helping people destroy the death star
and and
oftentimes we can get confused and we're
correcting the record today that listen
our our ultimate goal
the d
is to destroy the death star but through
others
we we want to serve others we will be
great at think media and shine the
brightest when we help the most people
win
and the hero at think media is the
silver play button pictures we're
getting and the monday board that we're
filling out with our students getting
results think about what our mission is
our mission
is not
to help 25 think media team members live
the coolest life possible and be able to
do whatever they want and just be able
to like flex possessions on social media
that is not our mission statement our
mission statement is to help 10 000
purpose-driven people
create a full-time living doing what
they love while making a difference in
the world with youtube and online video
they're the heroes
now of course we have to be players
coach coaches so if we haven't gotten
the results
that we want to help them get then we're
not qualified to coach
but that's why yoda could be like yo dog
you don't even know how to use the force
let me just close my eyes hum a little
i'ma lift this x-wing that's why obi-wan
could just you know come up to the storm
trooper and just be like let us pass
he's like okay you guys are good go
ahead and pass these guys already knew
it was but they realized that there was
someone named luke skywalker
who had a mission who had a story who
had challenges who had obstacles to
overcome and he was on a mission to
destroy the death star and they were
guides and they were servants
in helping him accomplish his mission
we want to help 10 000 purpose-driven
people
we are already making a multiple
multiplied impact and it's really
exciting but the only way we can create
the leverage we need to really
accomplish our mission on the earth is
if we activate and empower others that's
what leaders do leaders don't create
more followers leaders create leaders
and ultimately we are wanting to amplify
and promote and serve
our community and help them not just
learn these skills but learn these
values because i really believe not only
is our mission to help 10 000
purpose-driven people create a full-time
living doing what they love while making
a difference in the world with youtube
and online video but it's to experience
that success without losing their soul
true greatness
and as the world gets more selfish we
want to spark a movement
of service
well that wraps up the session number
three we've got one more session for you
that will be coming in just a few short
weeks and i hope you're getting value
out of all that we're delivering through
the at your best series and if you've
not yet picked up carrie's book at your
best i'm gonna encourage you to get that
book in your hands you can get it on
audio or on digital or the real copy you
know like a real book copy you can get
that as well and read that book it's
gonna really inspire you to be at your
best and here at think media that is
exactly what we want to do we want to
serve you well and i hope that you're
experiencing that here through the
podcast and for our community and our
customers that you're experiencing
hopefully what we're talking about that
is a huge part of what we do here is to
serve you with excellence now uh we ask
you to rate and review the podcast and
we get to share someone from our
community every single week and today
it's from mulatto lee and i chose this
because he said so good but then he said
so good okay i know i'm not a millennial
but can you just put that audio like
audio over that so good thank you so
much it's um from brandon cook of
the brandon lee cook
thank you for rating and reviewing the
podcast and making it fun for me to get
to embarrass my teenagers here on the
show
we want to thank you for being a part of
our community rate and review it if
you've not yet done that and we'll catch
you in the next episode here on the
think media podcast
[Music]
you